[Music]
hello there
you caught me in a good time I just
finished my 3d printed Settlers of Catan
set I'm working on this for months this
is a set of Catan titles that was
modeled by a guy named John Wall on the
Thingiverse form and another guy by the
name of the Khans eeeh modified them so
you could add magnets into the base so
they stick together
the kanji I also modeled this whole
storage system this box that slides
together and this one holds all the
pieces and then also there's city pieces
town pieces road pieces whole bunch of
good stuff not to mention your number
pieces and your piece which is now been
replaced by a tornado I worked on this
for weeks and weeks and weeks each tile
took six hours to print 37 tiles here so
the tiles alone amounted for 222 hours
straight of printing then there's the
box
there's the little storage hexes which
go on top so you can stack them without
having the tiles rest on all the details
not to mention all the other world
tokens and mishmash miscellaneous things
so 222 hours alone that's almost ten
straight days of printing I can't claim
any sort of creativity for the 3d
modeling but I can claim some creativity
for painting and that's honestly where I
was looking to spend my time sitting
down and painting something is very
therapeutic it's very relaxing I spent
all my day looking at computer screens
spending a little bit of time looking at
something physical in my hand is really
really nice and if you watch the other
Qatada video that we made I'll talk
about how there's no troubleshooting
there's no errors there's no bubs it's
not that kind of stuff when you're
painting something and that's really
really nice and really comforting people
come to us all the time asking us to
create a pitch for this or put something
together for that so you're always on
the spot to be funnier to be smarter to
be whittier to have a good idea and it's
important that you take some time to do
other things because you need
inspirations for where those good ideas
come from it's why you don't skip leg
day at the gym the same thing goes to
your brain you have to do other things
with your brain keep the whole thing
exercised
[Music]
where you guys going today they were
going for our meeting very special
meeting so trying to get a movie made
and it's a complicated process involves
a lot of parties it's like pitching a
small business to the bank you come to
the bank with your small business plan
and you're looking for a small business
loan you're gonna pay him back at a
certain rate when you make a film you
actually start an LLC basically a
corporate structure for the film itself
all the parties that partake in this
will generally have connections to that
LLC we are in the process of starting
all these things but one of the key
things to do is to get all our ducks in
a row with our writer so we wrote this
piece with Andrew Allen or as I should
say he wrote it but Sam and I of course
were very instrumental and story and
world and all his kind of stuff Andrew
was the guy sitting down at the end of
the day banging those keys on that
keyboard we are going today to meet with
his manager and agent to basically lay
out some of the ways that the deal work
with him
what kind of ownership he'll have on the
piece chances are the dialogue is going
to then spin into the direction of how
to get this thing made the long story
short we finish the script I mean no
script is ever finished like it always
continued to be tweaked but I can sit
down around a campfire and tell you a
dang good story right now it's a very
big step and that's a great spot to be
in and I'm really happy with the script
a lot of you remember tether we still
see comments all the time saying you
know what happened to tether what's next
in tether I'm a big sci-fi buff and
sci-fi people have a tendency to get
really invested in the world building
the logic and these crazy set up so the
story but when you're making a film the
film needs to flow it needs to have a
focus and a point believe it or not many
films need to be all short stories in a
way I mean that's why a lot of short
stories actually get adapted Minority
Report was a short story because a 90
minute film puttered minute film might
seem like a long time to tell a story
but in reality now a lot happens in
those movies yeah your characters doing
their thing something crazy happens they
solve it to the end it's pretty much
that the toilets running upstairs
continuously
they got a treadmill come with me Nick
let's go fix them hey Sam what you're
doing welcome to my chambers this is
where we keep all the rare limited
edition merch that we've sold and that
can no longer be purchased anymore we're
about to create extras because this
Black Friday every single piece of
limited edition merchandise you've seen
in the store is gonna be made available
for purchase once again that means if
you've missed your favorite hat if you
missed your favorite shirts you'll have
one final chance to make a decision of
whether you think it's worth owning this
Black Friday do not forget to check out
quarter digital comm slash store and
thank your favorite limited edition
merch from this year here's the entire
board oh look at that stick together
when his penis I tried to give it a bit
of an overall vibe I wanted to kind of a
pastoral countryside summer feeling so
it worked in a lot of like golden hues
into this design when there's green but
it's more of a yellow-green
I didn't want to go to rich dark green I
learned a lot of new painting techniques
doing this that are really valuable I've
never really panned miniatures before
but I have my chance here so like for
example this mountain I wanted to snow
to kind of run down the side of the
mountain climbing those crevasses like
you see I'm real mountains so I did as I
painted this part white first and then
on the tip of my brush I got some dark
gray / black paint and I lightly brushed
over the surface just catching the tips
of the rock and that gave me the kind of
dark veins of rock that stick out
through the snow and this is the
technique known as dry brushing it's the
raised parts of your design of your
print or your model or whatever you're
painting will catch the paint beauty is
just a very fine amount of paint on a
very fuzzy brush so I did the same
technique here for the desert piece
where I paid the whole thing brown first
and then got a little bit like a
yellowish orange and just lightly brush
the surface the raised ridges of the
sand would catch the paint and pull it
off the brush same thing for the
skeleton I just put white on the brush
and then just lightly brush the surface
and the skeleton once again would catch
the paint from the brush
that's one of the things with mini
painting is that you want to add detail
to them and because they're so small
physics kind of help you out so you get
everything a darks coat first and you
paint up lighter and lighter tones on
top of it those crevices and cracks and
little nooks will stay and dark with
your dark paint so you can enhance the
lighting and you can enhance the shadows
that you are putting on your model and
paint extra light into your model and
that looks really nice
you fixed it Nick see you guys know what
stopping exciting
check the environment guys you look out
with one planet so we're trying to
figure out how to tell a story that was
much more feasible and actually doable
as a teacher film basically the entire
aspect of the story and world Heather
that we liked we condensed that into one
character and we took the other aspect
the other half of the world and the
craziness the logic who said that he
liked me condense that into one other
character and those two characters now
drive the story there's more characters
than two in this movie but it's a much
more focused telling story short all
those works been put into it the script
is more or less finished we're getting
some concept art put together right now
it's almost time for the meetings to
start to get this thing made we're
aiming for a tactical release maybe a
limited one I know movies are on the way
out just in general but it's still very
much a milestone that determines where
you're at in your career so that's what
we're gonna go for and if this all works
out we're gonna then go out and shoot
the movie that we want to shoot I'm
gonna shoot it in the way that we shoot
things remember so our channel talked
about how we can do these things that
Hollywood can't do because they do it
traditionally and old-school with all
this old equipment we've approached
things with a new way of doing things
with new equipment that still looks good
honestly you need to be able to shock
the viewer a little bit with films if
you want to be special you got to reach
out and slap somebody and they go and
you awaken them from their stupor and
then you tell them an interesting story
when they're paying attention then all
right we got our blueprint we got the
script next up pitch decks concept art
we have to convey the idea to a bunch of
people and bring our team together
for the first time ever the triangle
aspect ratio is being premiered here on
the salmon eco Channel and what better
way to celebrate it than to thank all
our patrons on patreon I stay frosty
Richard lender and today I'm the only
ace thank you Jason Iman thank you so
much for your support on patreon
Corey O'Malley I hope you're proud to be
part of this historic triangle aspect
ratio video thank you for your support
as well and finally Sean Witt where
would we be without you thank you so
Huckle I I think that was your fault
or maybe that was Toby come Toit's fault
thanks guys
and lastly I just want to thank my
patron fans Taylor Dunbar and James
Bailey this one goes to you last but not
least Brian and Togiak and Richard
Blackburn thank you guys for all your
support so can we be the first ever
filmmakers to make a triangle aspect
ratio film that we're just testing out
our new lens it's in a triangle aspect
ratio for all you out there with
triangle monitors you know we're just
experimenting with this tell me what you
think about the black bars obviously the
best experience is watching this on a
triangular monitor trying the phone that
came out like yeah the new triangle
phone Google doesn't fully support
triangular videos just yet or no cards
that's infuriating yeah they don't you
can't put em cards on your triangle
videos yet if you think it's cool that's
no makaan it's Alexa turn D goes light
to 100% brightness Alexa turned eCos
light to a hundred percent brightness
said it hmm
Alexa turn D goes light to maximum
brightness is this really on brightness
no it gets brighter than that Alexa turn
up Nico's light all the way I give a
percent Alexa turn Nico's light to a
hundred percent hey there's my little
duster okay give my a little jury duty
thing all the way here I have jury duty
coming up we'll talk more about that
another video Jake really excited we
have jury duty I'm actually excited to
holding someone's life in the palm of my
hands you know the decide if they're
innocent or guilty to throw down a
verdict if I'd have a mistrial I stand
up and I give a passion speech for why
he / she did / did not do it and ever
has her mind swayed and then
just like boom verdict anyways what
really come over here for oh this is one
point up once you're done painting
everything you want to throw a little
bit of a protective spray on there I got
this one still kind of shiny yeah locks
everything in keeps the paint getting
scratched off but if you guys have any
recommendations for a good matte spray
let me know cuz I actually even sprayed
everything yet cuz the couple sprays
have tried made it shiny so you see the
shine one you have to be on this side so
they're trilling paint is really matte
and there's no shine on that whatsoever
but this is when I sprayed here with the
matte finish it's really shiny and I
don't like that I don't want picking up
white streaks I want to just be
reflecting the pigment to the paint so
you can see the difference in shininess
there and I don't want the tops of my
trees to be white I want them to be the
color I painted them so if you guys have
any recommendations for a good matte
spray that's like really matte and dull
let me know I would really appreciate it
so all in all I played one game with
this so far and it was a total blast and
I look forward to playing many more it's
a nice sense of accomplishment to finish
something like this and now be able to
enjoy it and play with friends and I
think pretty shortly I'm gonna be a
Omega fan in this game as well if you
want to check out these models they're
on Thingiverse I'll have links in the
description below to the particular
model pack that I printed out big thanks
to the user to cons 'ya for sharing it
and a big thanks to Joe Wong for being
the first one to actually model these
tiles I also need to give a big big
shout out to mater hackers matter
hackers comments a website can also
check them out in the description below
anyways I hope you enjoy it if you want
to subscribe to the channel consider
subscribing it helps us keep doing cool
projects thanks for watching
very thin flat-screen triangular monitor
the little core that runs off to get
that thing beautiful it's perfect for
triangular video editing cause he has
your like video timeline down here and
stuff well you're like timeline and then
your triangle video is up here with your
it's like the scrubber here